thank you now we were looking pretty
good back then
hey I think we're still looking pretty
good well we come now to the final award
of the evening the one for Best Picture
the five films nominated this year are
so buried in the subject matter dealing
as they do with opposites attracting
criminals interacting history in
question cannibal indigestion and last
but not least a beauty and a beast and
here are the nominees for the Best
Picture
Beauty and the Beast Don Hahn producer
bugsy mark Johnson Barry Levinson Warren
Beatty producers
JFK a kitman ho and Oliver Stone
producers
Prince of tides Barbra Streisand and our
Andrew cars producer
Silence of the Lambs edward saxon kena
thought Ron bozeman producers
and the Oscar goes to the Silence of the
Lambs
to Kenneth
and wrong the
Garrett gets when our executive producer
is a partner in this as are the hundred
and twenty other people who made this
film this is their award we all
especially want to thank Thomas Harris
whose extraordinary imagination made all
this possible and give our deepest
gratitude to Arthur Krim Eric Pascale
bill Bernstein Mike Medavoy and Marc
Platt of Orion Pictures for their
support and unwavering commitment to
artistic freedom throughout the years
we've got some personal thank-yous I
personally want to thank my parents my
family my teachers especially art Murphy
and Jonathan Demi my mentor and dear
friend I'm Kenny uh Gil I need a
teleprompter I feel like John Wayne I'm
ten feet tall in addition to the Demi
family and the Orion family I want to
thank my family my wife who's been the
star of our family for 50 years Angie
and my son Tim our son Tim in Vermont
and his family and to our daughter Robin
and my partner Robin Fajardo in New York
thank you very much Thank You Academy
Ron Bozeman I've run into my family my
parents my dubber in Texas my wife my
love Kyle our young young son Regan and
to the family of filmmakers that
Jonathan has assembled and with whom
we've made some wonderful films
particularly this one and to all of you
for your support for this movie
we thank